le psg a confirmé hier que des
formulaires avec des contenus illégaux
ont été utilisés entre 2013 et 2018 par
la cellule de recrutement de son centre
de formation
le club dénonce une initiative
personnelle du responsable de ce
département marques dester l'ofppt et
lui reconnaît une maladresse une erreur
pour chaque joueur en plus des noms et
prénoms une case origines permettait de
préciser français antillais maghrébins
ou afrique noire à la ligue de football
de martinique on se dit stupéfait le
racisme et les discriminations sont une
triste réalité du football français
souvenez-vous 2011 joue les deux
personnages les plus importants de la
technique française à savoir le
directeur technique national
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de jean
françois blaquart et laurent blanc pour
cette affaire dite des quotas
souvenez vous également des propos de
willy sagnol entraîneur de bordeaux sur
les critères de recrutement des
africains donc aujourd'hui il faut
dénoncer cette discrimination ethnique
racial mais aujourd'hui il y avait
également une autre réalité celle des
discriminations sportives dont sont
victimes toutes les lignes du tram à
guînes la ligue de football martiniquais
espère que des sanctions seront prises
kevin parent semin qui a joué dans
l'hexagone aux états unis et en afrique
espère que cette discrimination n'est
pas l'apanage de tous les clubs
nationaux et pourtant je les ai vécus
levée du
je suis comme ça c'était souvent kevin
son entier
c'est pour ça qu'il parle maintenant
c'est pour ça a été mais comme saguenay
comme cy waits et si c'est vrai que
c'était frustrant à l'époque
maintenant j'ai un peu de recul il voit
là je ne souhaite vraiment aucun jeune
d'être heureux de ne pas avoir la
carrière qu'ils méritent parce que à
cause de ses juges en tant que
sélectionneur de l'équipe de martinique
mario bocaly dénonce lui aussi ce
fichage ethnique mais il espère que les
valeurs du sport sauront dépasser le
racisme on a vu 98 on passe un moment
donné que ça va arranger les choses
quand on voit le la superbe but en 2018
tous les joueurs ont vraiment
revendiquer le fait d'être plus ethnique
je peux le dire comme ça donc on espère
que nous sommes en ce sens dit que ce
sont des messages qui vont passer et que
ce sont des messages qui vont aller
au-delà de ce qui se peut se passer de
la cité que justement le sport permettra
d'initier peut-être autre chose
la ministre des sports a quant à elle
exprimé sa consternation
elles demandent des sanctions
disciplinaires voire pénales
[Applaudissements]